just give us a sense about the situation
where you are
yes so we uh as um
you've received us very well very well
in a very high level in uk quite
recently and you know we think that uh
mps specifically women
have to be joining the diplomatic
missions because as
uk citizens know
men from 18 to 60 are not allowed to
leave the country with few exceptions
of this rule
which was the decision of
the
at the highest level taken and voted and
supported by the parliament
at the moment with
we are in the in the regions
which were represented we are traveling
across the country as well a couple of
days ago we've had another very
important meeting in kiev voting on more
than 20 laws which are linked to social
life economy
supporting of business medical sphere
and of course security and defense
currently um
as the governor and the city mayor of la
levith the city which you've mentioned
located in the very far west mentioned
rightly yesterday there is no more
secure place in ukraine so you know when
we are being asked are you safe right
now the safety is quite uh can be
temporary
for the moment we still face
very
harsh difficulties with securing the
humanitarian corridors and that's uh um
how we are trying to raise this uh issue
across the globe so that the
international red cross unhcr and other
international organizations dealing with
human rights and have an actual mandate
for this uh green corridors would play a
better and more decisive role and we
salute the efforts of the minister um
of the temporary occupied territories
she's doing a great job and more than
seven southern people are being rescued
every day so let's say 90
of the agreed corridors do work
we have some shortages in terms of
access to
some smaller cities and one of the hero
cities which is of course mariupol
becoming second aleppo or a symbol of
the
of this um
glorious fight of ukrainian nation
against russian invasion russian
occupation russian aggression but there
are many more
of such marijuanas which are the smaller
okay small smaller cities next to the uh
for instance my home city harkev the the
uh in a far in the east uh which is uh
just two hours or so sorry 40 minutes
away from the russian border the city of
izum which is which is translated as a
raisin or the city of bhagavad-gita uh
chuguev and other ones we are trying to
do our best so that our volunteer groups
which are operating on the ground can
reach out to the people to deliver food
medicine and water what i have to
mention right now that twice already
during this week russian soldiers shoot
in the civilians who were queuing next
to the post office in harkin and next to
the hospital
city hospital to receive humanitarian
aid this is a complete disaster we have
we have more than 80 people who died and
many more injured this is just an
absolute fact of a war crime against
ukrainian civilian population this is
definitely not soldiers against soldiers
this is something which is going beyond
the normal understanding understanding
of war conducts of any point therefore
the um prosecutor general office human
rights organizations are recording these
cases and it's very important to do it
right now so that they're not lost and
the
justice will prevail once we win this
war
it's so so um you know heart-wrenching
to hear you talk about incidents like
that you know the shooting of people as
they
queue for
supplies and you've also
in your work going around talking to
different countries in their parliaments
you've spoken out about about what's
happening to women and you said that
women have been raped and hanged in
ukraine oh i think we may have lost you
but hopefully we've got you um
with you and we'll do a good
what is happening to ukrainian women
there is uh one case which was very uh
widely discussed recently because it's
been recorded and uh proceeded with the
uh general uh the prosecutor's office
and uh we're not going into details but
it's
quite a scary uh
scary scene when uh a civilian was
shot dead in his house in a small town
next to kiev
his wife was
i'm sorry but i have to say it raped
several times in front of her underage
child and this is something which
which is absolutely unaccepted in terms
of you know
talking about it public because there
are many more victims rather than just
this one case which has been made public
by the prosecutor general and of course
we are expecting many more of them which
will be public once victims will be
ready to talk about them so we can we
can bring them on that really
made um a huge let's say uh wave
information wave in the in the media
recently during this week i've been
interviewed by many journalists and we
will definitely not be silent about it
because the
during this
the war itself is violence
uh when the violence is sexual uh when
the violence is just a horror when you
know what what would be was this with
this child who witnessed once uh
uh the mom was raped just in front of
him or her that's that's just terrible
that's why you know when we've been
talking to boring johnson when we've
been talking to your home office
we've been talking to mps of uk we've
also raised this issue that this
aftermath which we are dealing with
right now the aftermath of war has to be
taken very cautiously very seriously and
to um take into account the uk
experience and the experience of other
countries uh which can help us in
dealing with psychologists uh and and
help to help help these people to
actually
leave over this these cases to to keep
going afterwards to keep living to
still be living in in in the normality
of this world and not this life that's
what we have to do right now but of
course justice has to has to prevail
that's why these cases are taken very
seriously and that we are very thankful
for the prosecutor general who is also
from harkev city she's a lady herself
and she takes it takes it very very very
harsh very strong and recently she
signed a memorandum with
two eu countries to proceed with such
cases and to exchange the information
i'm sure uk would join this working
group
thank you so i know it's so hard to talk
about these um things but it is so
important to give a voice to what is
happening so absolutely absolutely and
we don't have long left but just a quick
thought from you on the hope of any
peace deal it must be difficult for
ukrainians after
going through what you have to imagine
striking any kind of agreement with
russia but do you think one might
actually happen
president zielenski since day one in his
office always spoke about fair peace and
was always ready for direct peaceful
negotiations another part is that we've
witnessed for more than eight years of
the russian aggression uh where the
negotiations were done in trilateral
content group b between the
representatives of donbass ukraine
mediated by oac that russia is never
ready for a fair peace talks and you
know when we are remembering the first
round second round in belarus
during this time my home city was
bombarded what kind of approach to
peaceful negotiations is that so we
uh as ukraine as a state always rely on
international law international
humanitarian law we keep it up every
time nevertheless that the
when the aggressor is trying to you know
twist it over and use
absolute absolutely um you know
terrible it means um
office like you know let's do green
corridors to the occupied territories of
ukraine to crimea to donbass let's move
people to belarus russia let's take
let's take their passports away etc and
you know this this uh these casualties
which are happening which are now being
recorded
there there are no means for them to get
to get away with it anymore it's been
the the
the the world was half blind through
this eight years of war but i think now
it's the time when when we all have to
press russia as a collective west as a
collective international society to be
responsible for the actions that they
for the brutality uh which are
which they are conducting right now so
we do believe in peace but only based on
international law and a peace which is a
fair piece